the news is pretty heavy right now
there's a lot going on in the world and
it's super important for everyone to
stay informed but it's also super
important for everyone to remember that
there's still a lot of good things
happening in the world and to try and
laugh every once in a while so that's
why every week here I'm good news gaming
we're gonna take some uplifting news
stories that maybe got lost in the
shuffle and highlight them as well as
look at some weird memes and strange
things that people are doing in video
games that's it that's the pitch I don't
really have much else to intro with so
let's just look at some wholesome stuff
can I just say thank God for Animal
Crossing it is the perfect wholesome
game that I need in my life right now it
makes me feel super accomplished I'm
watching my Island grow I'm paying off
loans I'm building cute furniture the
only thing I really want from it is for
my boy Roald to accept my invite and
move into my Island but until he does
that I think I'm just gonna keep on
enjoying his unofficial Twitter account
anyway New Horizons came out just as
everything started to hit the phone and
we had to cancel well all of our plans
you know were just socially distance
ourselves which is a very good thing
don't get me wrong it's very responsible
and it's a good thing that we're doing
it but at the same time it especially
sucks with people who had big life
events coming up like birthdays weddings
and christenings it's been amazing to
see how Animal Crossing has been
bringing people together in this weird
time when everyone's been forced apart
on reddit user ash Bush posted that
their wedding unfortunately had to be
canceled
but little did they know that their
fiance and all their best friends had
conspired to throw them a wedding inside
Animal Crossing and if you look at
pictures they're full of cute little
details like an aisle for them to walk
down and a white dress was dropped at
the end of it so that they could wear it
as well as these cute little
personalized tiles on the floor that had
their initials on it's super
heartwarming and there are so many
stories like that in fact loads of
people have been throwing birthday
parties in Animal Crossing everyone's if
your birthday
as well as going on cute little Museum
dates are there significant others which
is very very poulsen but if catharsis is
the name of the game then may I suggest
doom eternal which also came out on the
same day I find that ripping and tearing
is pretty good for taking you mind of
things after the game release drought
from earlier this year I am super
excited the games are starting to come
out more frequently I mean we've got the
control DLC Resident Evil three remake
persona 5 royal and the upcoming Final
Fantasy 7 remake I mean I say upcoming
the Final Fantasy that is unless you're
in Australia where they're just selling
it early and I'm not jealous at all it's
completely fine I don't know what you're
talking about but not content with just
keeping us happy by giving us more games
to play the gaming companies are
actually doing a lot to help the world
at large
Ubisoft CD Projekt RED and Riot Games
are just some of the companies who are
donating loads of money to kovat 19
relief and the new Humble Bundle is
incredible if you pay something like $30
you get over $8,000 worth of games and
ebooks and all the proceeds go to
charity so that's an incredible deal and
it helps out
companies like Razer have completely
pivoted to manufacturing surgical masks
for those who need them and NVIDIA is
encouraging its users to download the
folding at home app which lets you
donate your PC processing power to help
run simulations about how the corona
virus works and they'll hopefully lead
to us understanding more about it and
how we could stop it it's a super cool
way that we can all help out from home
and I'll make sure to drop the link in
the description below so those are the
new stories and now here's a bunch of
just miscellaneous things from games
that I really enjoyed this week
first up half-life Alex came out and
people have been going mad using the
hand tracking to do things like flipping
off combine soldiers drawing on the
game's whiteboards yes they've been
drawing rude things but I'm just gonna
show a picture of gabe here and my
personal favorite teaching kids geometry
cuz even those schools are out always
quiet time to learn mountain blade to
bana lorde released into early access
something like seven years after it was
originally announced and so to celebrate
which use a hand
streamed the game for a full 24 hours
dressed in a full set of armor in
speaking of banner Lord Reddit user just
this so discovered that if you hit R
during character creation you can play
the full game as a baby do with that
what you will I know I went on earlier
about how Animal Crossing was bringing
people together but sometimes it just
doesn't work I found this amazing
article on livedoor about a company that
tried to hold all their meetings in
Animal Crossing and they had a list of
pros and cons the pros were that it was
definitely more fun than Skype or
discord or slack but the cons were you
couldn't send attachments to people and
people kept getting distracted because
there's a lot of cool things you can do
in Animal Crossing also there isn't
really any private chat so they were
afraid about everything leaking but
honestly the thing that really cheered
me up this week was actually an April
Fool's gag
I never expected to say but if you know
anything about me at all you'll know
that I love overwatch I really love
overwatch and bliss it's April Fool's
gag for the game this year it was to add
googly eyes to all the characters but it
just not just the characters they also
added them to haunt those dragons I may
have watched this like five times in a
row
this is obviously a new thing that we're
trying so I would love your take on it
if you want to leave you know
suggestions for stories or some feedback
on the show chuck it in the comments
below I'm on Twitter Lucy James games
where was he kidding me keeping things
gaming focused but for a more worldly
look at some good news John Krasinski
has an amazing show called some good
news which is amazing especially if
you're an office fan because he's having
little reunions on there I said I'm on
Twitter
but if you'd like to chat more in the
GameSpot discord group then fire me a
message and we'll get you added it's
full of really cool wholesome people
just having nice chats about games and
stuff so would definitely love to see
you went now we'll see you next week
[Music]
you